it's time for screen junkies movie bides
hoot-hoot where my owls at what's going
on everybody welcome to movie fights
we're making that owl phrase a thing
also it's a very extra furry episode of
movie fights today there's a lot of pets
in the house and we want to let you know
what's going on we're trying to raise
awareness for care rescue la and you
know what we have an important person
here to drop a little knowledge about
care rescue la MS Jen Sturge or Jen you
want to uh break down a little bit about
what's happening thank you so much al
yeah this is a really special movie
fights because you know we brought a
bunch of our adoptable this is Kiki your
brother kotas somewhere running around
the studio and you know this is just
such a wonderful opportunity to raise
awareness for all the work that we're
doing we just started a patreon with the
help of the wonderful Nick Monday who's
one of our Foster's and we're trying to
raise awareness so that we can go ahead
and build some funds up and be able to
take care of more animals and not have
to turn people away because we just
simply can't keep up with the demands of
the community right now so any help you
guys can give us today check out our
patreon it's Karis qlae on patreon and
I'm sure we'll put the link up a bunch
of times it'll be on my Twitter Nick's
Twitter I mean everywhere it's probably
flashing on the screen right now I don't
see anything flashing on the screen but
yeah we'll get it there kitty cam I mean
someone's getting adopted today yeah
there's a lot of animals in the house
tonight and Jen I want to thank you
personally because you helped connect me
to this little girl right here this is
my dog Millie the dog
um hashtag Millie the dog and I love her
you know such a wonderful dog and I met
this dog I was like this is how the dog
is havin in the market for dog for
awhile and it's just like I love I love
playing matchmaker for people and
pastors like it's just my favorite thing
to do doctor yeah
Kikki love Danielle and I gotta say you
know what I I saved Milly but I also
think that Milly saved me I know right
Jen thank you so much we're here for a
good cause we're also here for some
movie fighting let's meet our fighters
you know what Chris you know we believe
in you if we believe in you in the booth
all right so uh Jen mentioned mr. Nick
Mundy and here's our old friend Nick
mombi good to see a brother hey thanks
for thanks for having me back thank you
screen junkies and fandom Rick fandom
for for letting Care rescue LA come and
you know bring some bring some awareness
to not just our rescue but like every
rescue
there's rescues all over the you know it
sure this is from Los Angeles but
there's rescues all over the country and
there's a lot of animals in need help
this is Leroy this is Leroy and he needs
a home this is Mike yeah today fighting
for movies and believing in the good
cause Mike Carlson and Mike Carlson made
a promise that if he gets a question
awarded to him he's gonna eat one of
these puppy treats that I brought with
me I did say I would eat dog treats but
I did not say they don't eat one of
those treats I'm I wrote this right now
one treat for everything every point he
gets awarded I would hope so hey all
right we shall see be DTV Gator man
Carlson always good to have you here
potheads you're extraordinary
yes of course my podcast podcast the
ride yes excellent Mike always good to
have you thank you and you know this
lady she is well she is a cat foster oh
yes oh hell yeah now with the cause and
you we adore everything she does all
over the Internet the schmoes hyper RPG
etc Emma five it's great to be here I
have two cats at my house right now I
didn't bring
that our care rescue la Fosters I didn't
bring them with me because they just got
fixed yesterday so they're not in a
great mood but they're very very cute
there's a orange girl and Norwich boy
and they're really cute and you should
check them out on my Instagram their
names are Darla and Drew actually did
dallara name them maybe yeah cuz I cuz
they came to me from the Monday's the
Mondays it was like that was their
stopover before coming to they all know
they had a sister too but she got
adopted so there's the success story
right that's awesome
Emma thank you for your good work with
animals you know house yeah I can
affixing I don't we need a fix old Dan
Merle over there he doesn't have an
animal in his lab Leroy loves movie
fights he wants to prove that wrong and
with Dan Merle on the Dan cam she's the
voice of the people and just an angel
sent from heaven above Daniel so yeah
right now the people say the puppies are
cute
there will be pols obviously there will
be several on Twitter and they are
amazing and you should do them but also
the only poll that counts for the show
is the one that's on the YouTube if
you're looking for instructions on how
to use that go down and click the
description below we will also be able
to help you in the chat can one of the
polls be are kittens cute or really cute
we could probably do it at least online
yeah okay good for sure great and
Danielle anything else to add so Dan and
I will be judging and if we are tied we
go to Danielle with the
we'll get the pole any which way but
your pole will factor in if Dan and I
are tied yeah and won't be showing it
either way until we get to the speed
round and that's when I have my own
opinions and I just don't think I can
have opinions today
Leroy's the tiebreaker and also please
join us and talk about this on the
hashtag movie fights live I will be as
much as I possibly can looking for all
of your memes many kind of fun aside you
have any of your opinions about how
things are going and I will be reading
some of those off throughout the show so
please join us on movie fights life
great and we'll also be popping over to
we have our I guess our version of the
Puppy Bowl over by the couch there with
several of our friends who's over there
so oh yeah hi everybody hi couch cam oh
it's just menagerie wonderful ever been
cleaner so there you have it and
remember for today's game the first
fighter to four points to win four
points walks away our Victor today who
and several of our questions maybe a
little bit animal theme to go with the
fun and hijinks we have happening here
so buckle up here comes movie fights
Chris do me a favor and drop the package
[Music]
it's main event time
oh yeah you're not gonna find a better
package anywhere question number one
okay this is definitely pet centric
pitch a new entry in the Air Bud
franchise pitch a new entry in the Air
Bud franchise the question gonna pop up
there it is
yeah Air Bud we know him we love him he
catches sick air pitch a new entry we're
gonna start with our good friend Nick
Mundy real quick aren't we supposed to
be standing oh you know the pote we had
podiums and there was standing for a
moment um we put the kibosh on that yeah
okay the people voted no standing okay
well good to know um kind of mess me up
well okay so Air Bud after so many
entries into the Air Bud franchise we
are exploring new and fantastical themes
for we've already determined that Air
Bud and his type of dog are the most
dominant species because they're so good
at sports so naturally when the end of
the world happens excuse me when at the
end of the world happens you know Air
Bud and his kind and dogs have now taken
over like Planet of the Apes and they
are the dominant species humans are
nothing but like I would call them pets
and they're living they're just they're
just treated like you know like animals
like their tree like animals and so now
Air Bud the a dog a suburban affluent
dog family has adopted a new human and
one of their kids is playing sports and
he's not that good at sports and that's
when they adopt a new human named Bud
who's really good at sports so what this
movie describes and details is about the
story about a human named bud who gets
some air this is Air Bud Apocalypse Now
total role reversal there okay next one
kind of like duality of man a little bit
Oh
we'll learn more about that all right
Mike Carlson what is your foray into the
Air Bud world all right I'd like to
start out with a quote from my amazing
pitch best pitch I would also say
whether there ain't no rule that says
the dog can't do virtual reality
all right I'm talking about ready canine
player 1 ok we're talking eSports you
know me I'm a futurist I'm a guy who
likes to think forward ok I don't want
to play these old boring sports I want
to take it into a new realm into a
virtual realm
I want air but doing all the fun things
like racing a car falling in love with a
human woman I want to do all the
wonderful things we saw in the film
ready player one but with a dog and a
dog who does it with style and grace and
amazement let's be honest we can do
anything we want here we can meet Lassie
we can meet Rin Tin Tin we can meet Toto
we can meet a sexy human woman the dog
falls in love with alright we can do it
all ready
canine player 1 Wow a parenthesis
everybody that's really good yeah yeah
and it's already a very quotable moose
thank you yes
ok I'm a fight great so here is the
thing about the Air Bud franchises Air
Bud has constantly been reinventing
himself he's played pretty much every
sport on the planet
he's got puppies that go off and do
their own sports so I think that what we
really need to do is bring Air Bud back
to his roots with a good old-fashioned
comeback story you see Air Bud the the
dog from the original film buddy he has
fallen on some hard times all right he
was really hot there for a while maybe
got a little too big for his britches
got into some dog drugs maybe has a
former arrest on his record and he's
he's fallen on some hard times things
did not go well with his wife Molly and
then he's brought into the game again
this is about Air Bud getting back to
his roots season he's an old retired dog
at this point recovering drug addict
probably and and and he he reconnects
with Josh the human boy from the first
few arrows eventually like rode off and
he went to college he reconnects with
Josh so again we're really getting it
back to what Air Bud is all about and he
has to come down
to the basketball arena for one last
stand to revolutionize the game of
basketball and get back to where it all
began in Air Bud back in the bud this
Wow
three very we'll explore that okay three
very different films that will never get
made find it out you guys these are the
most depressing pitches I've ever heard
a post-apocalyptic future and unlike a
drug-addicted dog does a comeback story
I totally agree with your set but again
I am pitching a comeback story on top of
that we have so many franchises now that
are so concerned with constantly
reinventing themselves and appealing to
a new generation of people why not
create a film that speaks to the
nostalgia factor that we got going on
nowadays and tugs at the heartstrings of
the people that were originally in to
Air Bud and made the film and the
franchise itself such a success I don't
want to see a junky dog on the street
don't like to see that it's all about
how he comes back from that it's like
what slash max in a movie it is
everybody like slash back oh okay what
my movie is is is a movie about
wonderment and amazement about a human
who can play basketball really well but
those doesn't want to see that no one's
ever seen that ever and this movie human
who plays basketball really well against
a bunch of dogs I'd argue that we've
seen one or two humans play basketball
really well just like in life okay well
in the movie well excuse me Emma but if
I was doing your piss what I would do is
take the Rocky Balboa
you know route and then air buds wife he
loses her to cancer and he opens up an
Italian restaurant
the happy reunion of the ending where he
and Molly get back together and they get
back and he reconnects with his kids and
again it's a very uplifting tale of you
know being a husband and overcoming the
odds and to realize that you are still
relevant even twenty years into your
career this is crazy
first of all there's so many questions
about your pitch like do the dogs talk
in this universe yeah well how do they
talk what happened there what and adults
rise up and I like start putting us in
like prisons inside and now they found
it what do you mean yeah you didn't say
it I'm pitching things now let me ask
you my girl said about your pitch the
animals talked in your phone do they
talk well they can in virtual reality
because they've developed a thing to put
on the animals throat sure that senses
the bark and can decipher what they mean
in English he's not gonna argue that
ready player one would have been
immensely better if it had been about a
dog but it's still ready player one
which is a media online player one the
book was so much better than the movie
like well I'm writing the script to this
movie so it's gonna be a lot better
okay I'm adapting from the book but also
I'm adapting from my brain which is much
better than the book and the movie I
think your movies I hate to say rely too
much on nostalgia where my movie is
about a human who's good at basketball
never happened before into nostalgia but
it is not reliant entirely upon that
song no it's taking a hero which people
love and then putting them in a
situation that wasn't expected which
people hate have you know I mean that
people like their heroes to be exactly
where they think they're gonna be in
their heads for the last 100 some people
I mean he's your Air Bud might as well
throw his lightsaber on the ground that
was one of my favorite Luke Skywalker
moment moments that ever happened so
there is definitely a demographic bring
up laser but here's the thing is that is
is going off of this idea that you guys
are both pitching these air buds that
are very much for a new generation it's
like post-apocalyptic it's eSports it's
whatever there is still the appeal for
the new generation of the people who
felt like they couldn't connect with the
perfect buddy and now buddy has gone
through some hard
we realized that he is he is vulnerable
in the squads just like the rest of us
but that doesn't stop him from being a
hero at the end of the day what kind of
drugs was somebody using on mr. he got
into some some real hard puppy chow yeah
okay puppy chow meas heroin hide from it
let's be adults yeah I feel like people
want heroes to stay exactly the same
over 25 years
we don't want to deviate from that
that's why it was my movie its dogs who
having a human for a pet who's really
good at basketball would you cast is
this human for the pet Nick Mundy
Michael Jordan Michael okay so Michael
Jordan it's in between golf rounds okay
they shoot this movie in three days this
is crazy
Augusta three days it takes at least a
week to make a movie okay well yeah when
it's all CGI and virtual reality like
yours okay real movie about grit yes
can I give you a little scene from the
movie yes give us a little more of your
okay there right now he's in like Air
Bud is in a crazy race like it's a crazy
race and all these crazy cars so a dog
is getting to drive a car which is
awesome and all of a sudden the bad guy
who is played by let's just say Michael
Jordan okay makes his return to acting
he attacks Air Bud and then everybody
saved by Clifford the Big Red Dog all
right isn't that cool and then after he
wins a race Air Bud kisses a human woman
saying there's interspecies love it
doesn't matter when you're in the Oasis
okay I'm like what's happening is that
okay like yeah I get it it's it's
everybody's ready player one but that's
what it is air bred ultimately is a
sports movie that have to give in it and
this is not a sports movie and I agree
just like my movies a sports movie and
let me pitch a scene to you one of the
dog children is not very good at
basketball or his team is and they're
like oh we need another player and
that's when they call bud they're human
to play on the team which seems
preposterous but
he's really good at basketball and they
help this your final thoughts it's a
human plan basketball great excellent
Mike any anything else to say
wrap it up yeah look we run everywhere
with the Air Bud franchise and then they
obviously spun off into space buddies
and there's a whole different franchise
that's a hundred percent true they went
into space it doesn't even have to be
sports the animal facts check me later
became right then knows I know my Air
Bud but we want to take this to the next
level we want to unlock the
possibilities of Air Bud completely and
what better way than to going to
everyone's favorite virtual reality
realm the Oasis all right thank you Mike
Carlson and Emma fight since Air Bud has
branched out into so many different
sports stories already I think that
again it's really about bringing Air Bud
back to its roots which is about a dog
that was a basketball sensation and this
is the story of a dog who was a
sensation who got washed up and who's
gonna rise up again and be the hero that
we all knew and loved even when everyone
lost faith in him thanks to his good pal
Josh who brings him back into the game
time all right - you got a your hands
are full of cuteness
you got any facts over there I do we've
got you know Air Bud played basketball
he played football he played soccer he
played baseball
there was the air buddy's spinoff series
of films which did include going to
space yeah everybody's done many things
in his long and varied career on screen
dan you haven't changed a bit
thank you thank you Dan all right so
yeah three three very different movies
we had yet there are some compelling
elements in each of them interesting I
don't know Michael Jordan might be a
hard get 55 year old billionaire I don't
know if he wants to play bet him that he
can't do the movie that he would do it
okay I wish you brought that up over
there still debating here we are Mike so
it sounded basically like Nick yours was
like plan
the Apes except with dogs and humans
like basketball yeah Mike you were
basically pitching a shot for shot ready
player one the one that can I found the
most compelling was Emma's story awry me
it reminded me of Mickey Rourke and the
wrestler except the Air Bud version of
the wrestler I wanted that's the thing I
wanted to see the most that grittiness I
want that story of a dog overcoming drug
for some reason that appealed to my
sense you were the most it was the most
interesting so I go with Emma fight damn
very different versions of and I was on
everybody's I was behind everybody at
one point or another but I think where I
landed was in a weird way when I
considered at first to be the most
outlandish concept that strangely as we
kept going there's more and more fully
fleshed out whereas the other ones I
felt fell apart a little more I'm gonna
go with Nick okay there we go
huckle so apocalypse Air Bud really
which one did you like
Shh okay what's the polls say Danielle
okay so the polls have it ooh with 43%
ready player one Air Bud Oh with 29%
washed-up Air Bud returns and with 26%
by the adopted human player all right so
we are all tied up one one one we go to
our newly established tiebreaker Oh
Danielle your opinion too of a judge yes
I again I thought that all of these were
incredibly great arguments um I have to
say that I was most interested in
washed-up Air Bud returns so I'm gonna
have to go with Emma Emma fight takes
the point Milly which one it was the
best ideas alright um Emma nicely John
um Mike Nick good luck getting
for your projects okay all right my bet
Michael Jordan
Chris can we take a look at the puppy
cam real quick oh my goodness hmm I feel
like we should just be doing vo over
that [ __ ] oh yeah yeah I know I should
just cut them this would be much more
power than movie flakes in general
ratings gold we slowly strip away
showing the fighters that we should--we
hearing the fighters it's just dogs and
cats but we still play the let them
fight montage yes yeah yeah thank you
for that let's go to question number two
if you're going to cast an already
famous animal as James Bond what would
it be and why so we know Daniel Craig is
gonna be stepping away soon meet
yourself but said he's not gonna do it
so who's it gonna be who's it gonna be
what animal ready player - let's start
with Mike Ross okay I hate I don't want
to hype myself up here but this might be
the greatest answer I've ever given in
the history movie fights alright James
Bond we need an actor who is suave
debonair a handsome can move but also
someone with a bit of Menace somebody
you can get stuff done I am picking the
most obvious animal answer there is I'm
of course talking about monta care
Siegfried and Roy tiger from there first
of all rest in peace to this tiger but
me this was the tiger that worked with
Siegfried and Roy for many many years
and he did so many live shows he's a
great performer but also he is the tiger
that attacked Roy which is side note not
his fault
Roy also says that that he was not
attacking who's trying to help him so
look we can't hold that against him
anyway
all right and his name is Monty care I
think I mispronounced it I have to look
it up again hold on all right we'll get
back to you on that
Emma five who do you got alright when
you think about James Bond you think
about somebody that's gotta wear a lot
of hats metaphorically speaking and
actually speaking so there is only one
animal for the job and that is the
Instagram famous Doug the
with 3.5 million Instagram followers
totally fits the moniker we have today
of casting social media influencers in
roles that they maybe don't necessarily
deserve but Doug the Pug absolutely does
he is the most fashionable dog on the
internet and James Bond is one of the
most fashionable characters in all of
cinema again you got to be able to rock
a lot of different looks you got to be
able to have your like nice we're going
on a tropical island and hanging out
with some babes kind of love you got to
have your like undercover spy kind of
look but ultimately what you need is an
animal that looks good in a tuxedo and
that my friends is Doug the Pug all
right I have some pug coming from Emma
five Nick Mundy who do you cast you know
I haven't been on movie fights for some
odd two-and-a-half years maybe longer
but there were two things that brought
me back one OK rescue Lily and doing
this episode and then two was the
question if you were going to cast him
already famous animal was James Bond who
would it be and why hmm because the
answer is as clear as day and I'm
surprised no one has said it already
because you want someone with style you
want someone who's debonair who's a man
about town sexy is held and a vicious
killer that's why I'm choosing
snagglepuss
he's a well-dressed gadabout who goes
all the fancy parties and he's a vicious
deadly killer hmm he has the cuffs he
has the bowtie he's ready to party and
he's ready to kill snagglepuss has made
famous by the laughs Olympics yes okay
there you go
hanna-barbera's drug-addled creations
from the future James Mont Wow a Vegas
show men an influencer and an animated
icon fight it out okay well first of all
like to point out that what snagglepuss
is uh animated again that the parameters
of this were not entirely clear but I
you would then
I guess would you be inserting animated
snagglepuss into the existing James Bond
universe it would just be animating
Jamie I still have no idea who your
character is okay okay but to that
question would you be Who Framed Roger
Rabbit in it or with James Bond be
entirely sure again that might be too
hard what that was okay you just take
that so a bio so guys gonna wear like a
green screen mask on his head no it's
snagglepuss it's a it's a pink guy it's
a pink cat with a bowtie and a collar
and but that's a dude that's like a dude
that seems less fun let's be honest like
it should be full snagglepuss if you're
saying it's human hands it's not full
saddle tiger my core yeah Mundek or as I
said if we can use deceased animals of
course I'm gonna choose Manticore and my
question then sure because the tiger
lifespan is only 17 to 25 years and the
tiger was he was he destroyed because he
no that's not true the tiger died 2014
and 2009 happened listen if we were
going with dead animals there was a very
famous sessile the lion which definitely
crossed my mind in terms of
consideration you should have chosen
because because the problem with wild
animals is James Bond he's got to be
able to blend in man he's got to be able
to get into those hip parties nobody's
gonna let my to call hiker just walked
into their bar but according to ten
years of shows in Vegas with no incident
one time it screws up we've all seen the
Christian Bale tape one time on
control and you bite someone that
happens okay ten years of consistency
means that Manticore is professional and
suave enough and deadly enough to do the
job as James Bond snagglepuss is a lover
both men and women he can infiltrate
into Fidel Castro's hideaway or some
bluesy you know you know person that
James Bond has to get clues from then
ends up dying which is problematic to
say the least
snagglepuss can get laid non-stop which
he does think Manticore can pull it down
no because he's too busy attacking em no
way he would never attack em definitely
ripped off Q's balls Monta Korres was in
vape Manticore in Vegas every night you
don't think Manticore was going
backstage
no man women other Tigers human women
should be the best animal representation
of Liberace I'm right there with you
just that's what I would pitch and I'm
confused that that's not the question
but snagglepuss even he's he's handsome
he's smooth he's a vicious killer
he's a Ranade killer
Tennessee Williams after he was
investigated by the unamerican
activities in 1955 we're also talking a
subversive we're also talking about an
animal that is fulfilling an acting role
which obviously when you take somebody
like Doug the pug who's used to being on
camera all the time now you don't get to
3.5 million Instagram followers by just
like hanging out in the back and never
taking a picture true done man that is
just that can fit into any scenario and
really embody that everything that is
international man of mystery about James
Bond done that York person is an
influencer and influencers aren't actors
and Doug the Pug would be let's be
honest octopus would be like the George
Lazenby James Bond it would be one off I
want to throw a question out there sir
I'd like you each to tell us what the
title of your new Bond film would be and
give us just a couple of couple
sentences of plot a couple sentence so a
little plot description and the title
and we'll start with the gentleman that
started it all off talking about this
round Mike Carlson all right
mine would be called James Bond Monte
Carlo adventure and just a few words
about the plot all right obviously it
takes place in Monte Carlo yeah there
are there's a gang of evil elk that have
infiltrated Monte Carlo and they're sort
of dealing with drugs and money or
whatever and Manticore has to go
undercover as an elk for over an hour in
the film and he has to dress up Lincoln
out and he infiltrates them mostly
seduces some elk in the process and
graphic will the elk Montek or sex be
it'll be very tasteful okay good it'll
be sort of a lot of like drapes and
stuff it's not going to be I don't this
is pg-13 we don't want to make the
broccoli family upset so yeah and at
that point then Blofeld comes back but
this time below felled is a Blowfish
different animals yeah nice all makes
sense
great thank you Mike I'm a fight this
one is called a James Bond
age of the fur baby and it is a
basically what it is is it is a James
Bond story populated by Doug the pug who
is playing the role of James Bond grumpy
cat is going to be playing the role of N
and essentially what it is is if you can
imagine the opening credits instead of
like naked silhouettes of women it's
just Scrolls of Instagram animals going
through and it is about a an Instagram
influencer animal who has taken over
who's hacked into the Instagram
algorithm and completely changed it so
it's James Bond's job to figure out
which one of the many animal influencers
who are going to appear in the film such
as Lil bub or Maru the cat and Marta the
dog and boo that little Pomeranian it's
and it's all about James Bond trying to
get in there and solve the mystery
of who hacked into Instagram and has
deleted all of the animals followers and
in the process he'll travel to many
exotic locations and where lots of
different adorable costumes okay great
we have the age of the fur baby
Nik Mundi a little bit about your film
yeah just real quick no offense to Emma
but no one's gonna watch a movie on
Instagram TV so this is quantum of stage
right even where foghorn leghorn has
taken over the new Confederate States of
America he's blown up the CIA and the
United States his spy infrastructure
that's why the Queen & M has to send
snagglepuss double-oh-seven
to America to infiltrate the new
southern colonies and stop the foghorn
leghorn from taking over the rest of the
United States of America same also also
also yeah there's like nine shots of him
getting out of a beach slow-motion and
those like bike shorts but to be Affairs
some some of the maybe the three
greatest entertainment related animals
we've come to know Dan Max and while
you're at it won't you tell us who's on
the battle Manticore was around for
about eleven years after the incident he
was actually about pretty young and an
indeed Roy was very very defensive of
the tiger said that it was the fault was
on him and then love the the animals and
continued to stick up for Manticore
authorized aspire life what's that did
you say it through a voice by I don't
know I don't know about that
Nick you brought up an interesting thing
which was about if we were picking an
animal to represent Liberace my pick
would be Templeton from the animated
Charlotte's Web and I really don't know
if there's another answer for that
question that's I think it might be
pollen and extra my choice I gotta say
if we if we were going just on selection
of character and reason for picking that
character I'm so sorry Leroy I would go
with Nick however when we got to the
pitch round or the pitch
portion I feel like Mike won me over
that that felt like the best hybrid
between character and bond and movies so
I'm actually gonna go with Mike thank
you Dan yeah there's ten more votes
before we decide so Emma I found that it
kind of lacked urgency the deletion of
Instagram pictures I and actually that
might be doing the world a favor in some
cases but I love hugs but yeah I think
that knocks you out and then yeah I I
agree that Montek or going undercover as
an elk and making love to Elks I mean
that's that that's hot that's
action-packed and Nick yeah I don't know
if snagglepuss he'd break into Fidel
Castro's hideout but Fidel Castro is no
more anyway I'm going up I'm going Mike
Carlson as well
Michael you get the point Danielle what
did what did the pollsters say for the
polls 51% for snagglepuss 2027 romantic
corn and 20% for Doug the Pug and also
please keep following us over on the
movie fights live hashtag cuz what some
people sharing images of the rescue
[Applause]
they're pets and stuff so if y'all want
more pets than you can possibly handle
please share them shared and keep
tagging that's great
you know Millie's been such a good girl
to treat time for Milly and Carlson
because in one Mike do you want it do
you want a meatless dog treat save it
for after the show can we get a shot of
the puppy cam looking long with a puppy
on his lap all right orab so though it
is mo one mic one Nick yet to score but
he is a bring another funny let's see oh
you guys it's a blind Friday yeah yes
let's put on the headphones and see what
the blind fight has in store first oh
they gotta pick a name first all right
what does that mean stop the tape oh
here we go Millie would you sit in that
chair like a person good girl oh oh oh
all right go ahead and pick one oh this
is who we're arguing again or something
yes okay I mean you want me to hand
there's only one left so do we look
swelling that my way
oh I don't know what this now yeah I
don't either
all right we'll see so what did it what
does your say
goofer goofer mine says Sandra and Jane
says Phil all right let's put on the
cans and see what's happening around and
no idea what's behind what
whoo 50 shades of gray people think that
just because we're puppets our sex lives
are whimsical and cartoonish but let me
ask you this here's a 4,000 square foot
dungeon complete with whips paddles gag
balls and a bucket whimsical hmm mother
exclamation point you know that movie
with Jennifer Lawrence that [ __ ]
can you imagine Oh with puppets oh are
they going melt brains um any Nicolas
Cage movie
I mean his acting teacher was a puppet
so it would be a pretty easy transition
so let's go a face-off puppet John
Travolta swap svelte phases with puppet
Nic Cage I'm not even sure if that could
make it any weirder but it would
definitely make it better okay
okay we were placed James Bond with
animals now we're replacing actors with
puppets
I am friends okay felted friends but
these were puppets say okay with the
term puppet yes so Emma yeah you have
faced off yeah start us on either way I
mean Phil makes a great point that
honestly like Nic Cage that's
practically a puppet already but can you
imagine you got the nice face swap as he
said with the puppet because the thing
is is when you take an actor that I in
my opinion you just replaced Nic Cage
himself with a puppet because he already
has that kind of like stiff and stilted
style of acting so why not why not
embrace it entirely and just go full
puppet Nic Cage face off national
treasure in a cage movie done got it
okay so we have Nick a lot of Nic Cage
talk replacing the cast of face off Nick
Mundy my my answer Mike
answer his mother movie I've I've seen a
lot directed by Darren Aronofsky and I
believe it was about sing
and and you know duality of man I think
my mother and then and then the reason
why puppets would be better is because
it's a Darren Aronofsky movie which I've
seen and those movies are always like
really screwed up so I'd be cool if it
was with puppets we'll hear more from
you shortly
Mike Carlson obviously Sanders said
Fifty Shades of Grey and I completely
agree it was what exactly popped into my
head when I heard the question let's be
honest folks most of us want to see 50
shades but we cannot handle it it's too
graphic it's too dirty we want something
that's a lot softer so that we can go
and be comfortable in the theater I want
to be able to take my family my mom and
my dad okay
puppets make that easy so we're not
actually having to watch human beings
engage in this type of behavior we're
watching puppet puppets it's much safer
it's much better therefore we can go
even farther it with the graphicness of
the movie I think this is gonna make the
Fifty Shades movie except accessible to
everyone of people of all ages and I
think that the franchise quite frankly
will skyrocket because of it but if you
make Fifty Shades of Grey
accessible to an entire general audience
including children then aren't you
taking away what Fifty Shades of Grey is
all about which I agree that is good
that it's not no that is not 50 shades
of grey is that it is for people who are
trying out anymore no but I think the
bigger question is the the cleanliness
of puppets in erotic situation yeah
doesn't seem that sterile Sean don't
seem sterile what are you talking about
well if there's say what you mean buddy
inside like a chocolate there's a lot of
what that's clinical it is the Winnick
aligning care there's a lot of body
fluids and then such and the other thing
how dare you say a puppet is better than
Nicolas Cage how dare you I think more
that it's like Nic Cage already in his
heart is a puppet so we just want to
embrace that and go full stop with it
but Nic Cage is more ridiculous than a
population
so he's better than a puppet and then
also mother with an exclamation point
[Applause]
because that's that's fun exclamation
point
puppets a mother is not fun and also if
you put puppets in one hold on and
mother is as we all know a couple's
relationship is tested when uninvited
guests arrive at their home and okay Ed
Harris and Michelle Pfeiffer are great
but would it be great if puppets as
Satan comes into their house I think is
one of the uninvited guests in this
movie it's like a puppet doing
jean-claude Van Damme splits and karate
there's karate in this movie we are so
uptight about sexuality in this country
I feel that a fifty Shades of Grey
puppet movie which slowly ease us into
the way of being a completely
comfortable with their own sexuality
nation especially with female sexuality
within this nation that is the point of
Fifty Shades of Grey is it is women
embracing their sexuality problematic AF
I am NOT gonna lie but it was a real
sexual awakening for a lot of women to
really delve into these erotic fantasies
and you put puppets in it it's not about
women anymore while they're women
puppets
speaking of women's sexuality there's
some of that in mother I think it would
be enhanced with puppets and also a
puppet would be better than Jennifer
Lawrence sing and face off and why the
puppets wouldn't have and I feel that
you know you have you have Nick Cage and
he is referred that's often in these
sort of ridiculous situations so you
take this like high intensity thriller
sort of action story with face off and
you put it in the from the perspective
of this puppet and suddenly you are it's
almost like you are more accepting of
the
crazy situation that is happening you
know what I mean except science has
already proven humans can take their
face and put on another human's face
science has proven that but you know how
hard it is to definitely cut felt and
then and then sew it back on it's
honestly though it's very easy to remove
a puppets head and put it on another
puppet that is not called head off it's
called face off you'll see the stitching
you'll see the stitching the bad
seamstress you'll see the stitching also
mother is surreal and disturbing and
those type of situations if there was a
puppet there would be more so okay
also Danzig's best song is mother that's
featured in it finally a topic you know
something yeah give us your final
thoughts here again I'm just saying
you're gonna get a great puppet face
swap we're gonna hire the best
seamstresses in all of Hollywood to do a
deft little sewing and it's gonna
completely change sort of the the face
of that movie but bring it forward in a
whole kind of new light all right Thank
You Emma Nick do you want to read us no
no yes my mother is great and so is
mother and so are puppets
Thank You Nick Mike Carlson my movie
will solve all the sexual problems in
America all right time Dan was I mean
Nick Nick gave already gave us a lot of
water facts it right off of IMDB yes and
believe it was from the fandom wiki
nicely done thank you for thank you for
using the fandom we're um yeah not
nothing to report there really okay
great
was it better if there was right ah
makes sense you know what matters our
furry friends yes so Nick yeah I mean I
that's kind of an unspoken cardinal rule
not to look up the film and read the
facts as yours I believe it was a blind
fight and no website okay I appreciate
that but thank you for the mother fun
facts Emma I believe you went you're the
entirety of your argument without even
mentioning John Travolta I
you're right yeah and I'm like what the
app so just for that and and he had an
angle on the film I'm going with Mike
Karl SATs they're going with Mike
Carlson damn yes
actually liked my I have been talking
yes and we both agreed I heard to him
and he convinced me for this very
similar reasons to also go with Mike
Ross all right Mike gets the point
Danielle Radford what do you know what
the polls say um the polls they're
saying Fifty Shades of Grey at 44% face
off at 32% and mother with 23% thanks
Danielle yep said you're doing a line
fight you might want to check to make
sure everyone's seen mother I mean the
blind fights question
so uh Danielle any memes or any other
answers for that question some memes but
we got a couple of great tweets from at
Sarah Wendling said can Milly be house
permanent co-host and then at Iron Mike
Wilson says why do I feel like the movie
fights live greenroom is just a
sleepover at Roth cornets place well I
got about three more questions I can
make a comeback can we get a quick shot
of the puppy cam quick Charlie puppy cam
let's just be let's just Leroy's awake
now strangely all right so uh Milly
can I ask you a question are you ready
for the speed round uh its speed round
time Mike and M are moving on Nick
you you brought you brought the charity
today you brought a lot of humor but
afraid you got have to sit this one out
ready yes it's three questions but now
things change things change around here
so it is time for the speed round once
again the first player to four points
wins emma has oh can we correct the
board please and by zone
point Emma has one yes can we correct
the board actually managed to get
negative one and that's the only reason
why I moved on there we go all right
Mike has two emma has one first player
to four points walks out of here no
there are no tents and it works
thusly I'll ask the question first
person to speak goes first and then you
get 20 seconds 20 seconds and then ten
second rebuttal ten second rebuttal oh
and Daniel Radford rather than
conducting a poll she will be giving her
own thoughts and Nick I might come to
you for your thoughts and I might
probably just answer anyway sweet all
right here we go
you guys ready yes speed round
activate who's the best chipmunk Alvin
Simon or Theodore Theodore I am gonna go
with Alvin okay we have one for Theodore
one Alvin Mike Carlson you answered
first 20 seconds begins when you speak
all right Theodore is the everyman of
the chipmunks you have Alvin and he's
cocky and brash I don't identify with
him we have Simon who's a nerd and I am
not that I am Theodore I'm a lovable guy
that likes to eat and likes to loaf
around he is a he is the way we are get
into the Chipmunks that's the person
most of the audience identifies with if
Theodore wasn't there the thing would be
completely inaccessible okay the other
characters are so all right 20 seconds
beginning it is called Alvin and the
Chipmunks so by definition we do not
have any other Chipmunks without Alvin
yes I understand that you want to have
other relatable characters but
ultimately it is Alvin that is the
driving force behind the Alvin and the
Chipmunks franchise he's the leader of
the group he drives the story forward he
wears red everybody knows that the main
character always wears red and so for me
that is the best chipmunk because I
always gravitated towards the person
that was dressed in red and was you like
narcissus folk just because somebody is
the glitter of group doesn't mean
they're the best Leonardo is not the
best ninja turtle it's obviously Raphael
okay he is the heart of the green
weird orders the heart of the chipmunk
if it wasn't for Theodore we would have
to have it would be some yeah Theodore
yeah it fine yeah whatever but but
without Alvin Theodore just exists in
space and doesn't do anything loafs
around as you say use the everyman you
would just sit home and watch netflix
all day with Alvin T as a star and yes
I'm alright you guys have a lot of
chipmunk knowledge Nick did you have
something you want to weigh yeah they're
both wrong because it's Simon because if
they were in space Simon would get them
out of that Jam thank you for that all
right Danielle Radford your thoughts by
the way I just found out mili not a fan
of the Bell tiny Bell
Danielle oh gosh yes so again both
really fantastic arguments I have to say
that as soon as Emma see no Alvin it is
them it is Alvin and the Chipmunks he is
the Beyonce and so and the leader does
wear red I had to go with them as
argument all right that's one and Aryan
say that the belly roll so that's one
for if the question had been who is the
most indispensable chipmunk then I think
that Alvin would have won hands down but
I think Mike made a better argument
about why Theodore had better qualities
than Alvin besides just being integral
to the group so I'm going with Mike
right so I I'm a little closer in
thought to Dan here because Mike used
Theodore as kind of a conduit into the
group that every man what would I do if
I was a part of this team and does I
don't get every little every leader
wears red yeah there was a time like
when I was a kid a lot of the main
characters wore red like the Red Power
Ranger
Chandler might gets the point Mike gets
a Chandler wore red all the time Heather
Chandler and Chandler from friends and
their friends worst winters I just think
of the red shirts that he Star Trek and
they get they get was also during the
era of next gen dr. Wharram all right
all right well wait there's a next gen
friends on a lootcrate t-shirt yeah okay
this is game right here Emma you need it
to keep it going Mike you take this you
take the day alright better talking Pig
movie Charlotte's Web or babe babe
Charlotte's Web okay babe from Emma
mike has Charlotte's Web Emma 20 seconds
begin when you speak babe is the story
about a charming relationship between a
pig and a hard-working farmer it is
about a little pig that really renews
this man's faith in his own life and his
ability to you know continue to live the
way that he does and within a society
that's really kind of moving away from
farming honestly and then you know babe
is is a pig that overcomes a lot of
challenges all right first of all who
cares about this man oh my god okay I
don't even give me 15 seconds who cares
about this old man in babe in babe well
you want Charlotte's Web this is a story
about friendship folks this is a story
about friendship in general not just
about one specific thing with a farming
industry who cares this is about
Charlotte and Wilbur
and what a friend does for another
friend this is a lesson that you learn
as a child that is so much more
important than learning about how to
irrigate crops babe there's a great
friendship story there as well and both
of them have a lot of heartache involved
however I would like to point out that
babe actually limbs say so
I'm there is a lesson to learn in death
also it's not just about friendship it's
about death which is another thing you
have to learn as a child and also
there's a great sassy character
Templeton the rat played by the
wonderful Paul Lin in the art animated
version this time Wow
all right what I throw down over the pig
booth it's very words that kind of round
I like to see about that kind of passion
and our competitors I think this one
went back and forth and went back and
forth I think Mike clinched it for me
when he talked about how it teaches you
many different kinds of death so I have
I have to go with Mike and he turned a
negative into a positive
okay 104 Mike Danielle Radford um gosh I
have to agree as much as I was really
hoping you were gonna go more in on this
idea about babe teaching a firmer how to
survive I have to agree you very much
Mike brought home the Sesame Street of
it all for me
and so ya know with Mike on this that
means my function you take it my car
[Applause]
[Music]
you might I'll eat a dog treat with you
just all through the match so Mike would
have to eat the maximum number of
Dorothy's or not I don't want to eat a
dog treat okay I'm gonna eat a dog treat
it's meatless Mike Carlson go ahead and
plug some stuff
oh podcast the ride it's about theme
parks but let's not worry about my great
podcast today let's worry the animal
patreon plug the patreon that's a word
plug into desk Nick um so awesome to
have you here hey always great to see it
great hat it's been a while so thank you
for coming in and please talk to us that
much more about the patreon and what you
do with fostering animals well look I
was never an animal person my wife was
the animal person but when Jen stirred
your and overcame rescue la keeps
bringing over adorable Bible games it's
that hard to love them so this
organization not only teaches you how to
foster then they bring bring food and
and they get them vaccinated and litter
and they get them fixed and they do all
this stuff so then people can adopt them
and they'll just take care of the rest
of their lives that costs money you know
so many of you people watching probably
have patreon zazz it is we figured hey
this is easier you just click put as
much as you can and then also if you
donate up to a certain amount you get to
name the animal look this one's Rick
Murtaugh so yeah it's a great
organization Jen starter and Rebecca and
everyone they work their asses off for
it it's got what it it's the thing that
made me come back and I just want to
thank everyone for having me and all of
us for doing this exterior Nick Mundy is
such an amazing foster and such a cat
person like a secret cat person I go
over and you would just be covered in a
pile of kittens and it would just look
so happy
yeah I'm borderline creepy cat person
why are you covered in them he loves to
give them all like weird names from the
eighties oh yeah
classic name um well if it's an old cat
it's gonna be getting too old for this
[ __ ]
right Emma thank you for being here
thank me for also [ __ ] yeah they say I
have to foster's at my house right now
they're the second pair of kittens well
there were three but when I already got
adopted that I have fostered four care
rescue LA and you know one of the things
that is so important I think about the
work that they do in that that people
might not realize as opposed to just
getting animals out of the shelter
necessarily is that you know these
animals are all in foster homes we don't
there is no shelter to put them into
they're pulling animals out of shelters
the three kittens that that Nick had for
a little while and that came to my house
like they were going to be euthanized
and so but because you know Jen and
Rebecca and everybody went in and got
them out of the shelter and into a home
you're also now ending up with animals
that are extremely socialized because
they've been living with humans in homes
rather than being stuck in shelters and
like to be afraid of you let me
piggyback that real quick um this little
bump up right here Milly
she's 14 years old I've had her almost a
year she was 13 when I got her she would
have done I mean I hate to bring the
room now she would have died in the
shelter yeah but Jen helped me find the
the foster community and get this little
girl and she's been a perfect angel sit
on my lap the whole time
you'll get a perfect pet and you'll save
a life and you'll feel good about
yourself and guess what the animal will
make you feel frickin great yeah and for
some of you guys on the fence all over
the country watching this or the world
mothers rescue age agencies all over
that call them up look you might not be
an animal person but you want to show
people that you're a human being and
maybe impress some girls or some gals
with some cute pictures
no we're talking to a certain set of
people that need to hear this okay say
you want to show that you're more than
just one thing you want to you're
well-rounded human being what's better
than to have a short term foster cuz
it's not forever
it's a week or two or three and then hey
I have all these cute photos would I be
a great person
to socialize with this is a great way to
do that it will definitely be good for
her Instagram account that was lame you
know I think Emma said the greatest
thing to me though is she was like you
know Jen I think I'm ready to foster
when she came to me and she was ready to
foster she's like I'm ready to foster
because she goes I think I need them as
much as they need me and I think that
that's just such an important part of
rescue work you know as you were at this
part in your life how were you wanted a
friend of her friends exactly and I
think that they add just as much to your
life as you do to theirs
true story i honest tell us again where
we can find that patreon it's at
patreon.com Care rescue LA there it is
it's right there on the Sun Mike Carlson
there's uh I have a rescue dog his name
is Edwin and I almost hit him with my
car and then we took him most shelter
and immediately regretted it cuz I was
like oh we should just kept him and then
we went back that's a nice story I also
have two cats of my own and watching
them interact with my foster kittens is
literally one of the most joyous
activities of my entire life that's
amazing well thank you so much Dan Merle
I mean what can you say what can you say
I love that there's a cat on Nick's
shoulder no I am a step by of a happy
stepfather adopted father to two rescue
kitties who are wonderful and everything
they said and then some and almost make
your life better they do they really do
they do Danielle what are you gonna
adopt a Corgi um it's and also I love
that you were mentioned you're not gonna
bring it down I appreciate it that at
least that time you acknowledge it
before you tell yes we remember the
Corgi incident as soon as I can
yes um as soon as I'm like literally
having my boyfriend like text me and
talk me down today take home an animal
today and and it's cute overload up in
here
[Laughter]
Kikki wash your car so it's fine it's
foster adopt be kind to animals and each
other I want to thank everybody Mike
Carlson nicely done but Emma Nick
amazing to have both of you and thank
you Billy biz and Chris in the booth and
thank you for watching tune in next week
for movie fights bye bye bye that was
for the championship
you